hey guys were up here at gamescom 2015
I'm joined by Lisa James now Lisa you
get motion sickness quite often they do
pretty bad so you decided to play some
of the bvr right
I did so it's actually vibe isn't it I
mean Rosie yeah it's what I've seen for
years
oh so we have we both when heads on
Raviv I guess PI you call it yep um I
don't go to sake in comparison to oculus
no motion sickness at all I guess it's
because there's no discrepancy because
you're actually moving within the space
and you have these controllers you have
these haptic controllers so what you're
seeing on the screen you don't have
hands like it shows you the controller
so there's no discrepancy then your
brains not arguing with you yeah I don't
know the science behind there don't know
the technology behind it but it did feel
more comfortable right yeah it wasn't a
strain on the eyes like I've used up on
us a lot I've used Morpheus a lot I've
even used the cardboard cardboard as
well give er yeah star VR there's a lot
of foam as well and they've all been a
bit uncomfortable after a while your
eyes start straining solution because
yeah I mean you're there's a crossover a
bit in the middle as well and you have
to try so what is yeah right okay yeah
well with life it was I didn't feel that
I felt way more comfortable I don't know
I just when you put it on you you put in
a white room it's basically you're in
the a loading section of Assassin's
Creed when you're in the Animus yeah on
you and then you see the controllers and
the first thing they tell you to do is
select from a color wheel and just click
the controller and a balloon appears and
that sounds simplistic that sounds
boring it's amazingly fun Nick is that
balloon comes out and you hit the
balloon yeah you hit the balloon and the
physics works perfectly
again we know it sounds boring but you
hit a balloon you can hit loads of
balloons everywhere that's what I did I
just flew like laser balloons everywhere
it was so much fun
right she talked about the demos that we
saw so balloon and then we went straight
into what was the first time the Aquatic
thing which was kind of the most amazing
way to debut
um the VR cruise you're on the bow of a
sunken ship yeah and it's what karma
first all these little fish swimming
around you and you can get top away at
them and they'll just swim away and we
both did the same thing at this point we
both turned to the right o because those
are stingray just thing right yeah we
followed this thing right other thing
right now we turn to the left
and there's a giant blue arrow so it's
one of the things where you know it's
not there yeah but like you still go
you're so completely in the space and in
your head you're yo your mind has been
completely tricked yeah you just think
it's that yeah and so the whale kind of
slowly comes out and then it kind of
stops and you look in the eye and you
have a moment we have a moment with it I
had a moment with it it's so magnificent
I had a matter with it yeah so we had
the deep blue yeah then what was the
kitchen so I kitchen from me was boring
my my only bad experience with it
because one of my controllers ran out of
a tree so I had to do with one hand um
so it was just it was just like
basically if you ever played EyeToy
there was a cooking minigame on i2e and
you know it's like it's like a VR
cooking mark yeah we were using these
razor controllers right these motor
controllers and so it was like the
kicking version of surgeon simulator
right yeah so we're just picking up
Tomatoes I'm putting in pac-man the
thing is at the end you make I thought
was gonna be a soup but it came out as a
cat house like well you sure you caused
her back right uh summers those games
okay
mmm I was not so impressive for me it
was the RTS demo so it does I'd like
that just because her concept it was
like a it was a table and there was a
miniature little battle going on kind of
something like akin to war hammer maybe
going on it the models were moving by
themselves in attacking and nuclear
I actually get a got on the floor get
under the table I was told to do that
I didn't just randomly get on the floor
on the floor no and you could you could
put your face in it
with me when you were walking through it
yeah that's right so basically this was
a digital table yeah with it with a
bunch of like tabletop games monks and
young men with rifle and they were all
moving around and stuff and you were
just like this invisible giant I could
see everything it would have been cooler
if you could have you know picked
something up and moved it but this is
really is a real observation checking
our work or our TSS you reckon like that
will help like I like playing RTS it's
not like moving units around the board
but dragon will help that you can sort
walk around and see what's going on
dragon or AIDS
no truck mouse yeah I'd rather feel like
a war commander and you know know my
chess pieces and that's right that's
right
I think you've melt and then watch it
play out yeah that's right yeah like it
might if you imagine oh [ __ ] or manager
as well can you imagine like placing
players where you want them to go yeah
yeah uh so then we was the Google demo
which was the paint oh it's a Google
demo Wow
yeah this is just as good as the
balloons so basically you're the the
haptic stick in your right hand is a
paintbrush but it creates it in a 3d
space so you can just walk around and
you had a different effect on your paper
so there's like a neon one there were
stars snow rain down so on your left
hand there was like this rotating pallet
thing and you could like to select
different things like different shapes
different colors different different
methods I undo and delete and everything
in your right hand you saw just created
in a 3d space this painting and again
that sounds simple but to make something
that's your own it was good to know I
felt sort of like I was in Fantasia just
right yeah yeah yeah you could just have
any dream yeah yeah that's what he's
doing but it was great because you can
move around and just sort of yeah I get
one point it looked like something from
in from a second Sun just you know after
you use the neon power and it was to
steal floating what did you draw
anything busy crazy we just do squiggles
and there's rainbows I try to do portray
of myself which was just a circle
say then we move on to the final one
which the best of the best
well yeah it was it was valves daughter
demo so this is one that is brand new to
Gamescom and I thought it would be a you
know like a spectator mode for dirty -
like looking down not at all it's more a
you know taking pieces from the dota law
and you're basically put in like a
Hagrid's heart it's like it's the
shopkeepers yeah this is a secret we see
we don't take those over it's going to
be quite obvious isn't it
it's the secret shopkeepers whatever
like their fans are gonna love it it's
that it's that fat dude in the shop the
shopkeeper the shopkeeper who hands you
some lights and baby talk he comes in yo
and it's again it's like the whale you
know it's not real but it just won't
he's just there it was lungi something
and you just take it oh yeah I mean it's
so beautifully rendered yeah it was I
know it sounds like hyperbole
there with Pixar s yeah it was a big
becoming yeah it was like being in a
Pixar movie and so then basically he
could scan around the environment right
so I had a lady like kind of directing
we did to what I was doing so the first
thing I did was using the light if you
clicked on the thumbstick or whatever
when it was a trigger
if you can trigger you shrunk and the
first place you shrink is on the top of
the table and so I didn't like this face
there's a piece of paper on it and you
just start reading it and go know what
you know but in a language you can't
even read I wound up in this turnaround
there's a giant spider yeah
again that doesn't sound scary but it
was incredibly scary it's like it's
incredible the way they've tricked it
like at one point I was standing there
and I hear something as well because the
headphone audio is done I guess it must
also work relative to where you are all
right well you mean that's like 3d audio
yeah because I had a guy like I heard a
guy and I just automatically looked up
and it was the roof and I saw it was a
hole in the roof when I saw a giant walk
past and then he just ripped off boards
from the roof and just appeared in like
I didn't see that I wish I did like that
sounds terrifying
so overall I mean something we're both
impressed by by I would I thought just
when I thought I was out for VR yeah
it's for me back in okay well for more
news and analysis on VR vibe optimist
rift and the rest stay tuned to game 2
up